1번째 원소는 sin(α)예요. 그런데 α의 범위를 0과 π 사이로 제한할 수 있어요. 다른 α 값은
α가 이 범위에 있는 벡터와 전역 위상까지 동치인 벡터를 주기 때문이에요.
이 상태들과 관련된 밀도 행렬을 Pauli 행렬의 선형 결합으로 표현해서 계산하면,
화면에 나타난 식을 얻어요. 그 계산은 여기 나와 있지 않지만, 직접 해보면 그게 나올 거예요.
그리고 이 상태들이 극을 지나는 소위 대원을 형성한다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
구체적으로 α가 0일 때 북극에서 시작해서 본초자오선을 따라 내려가다가
α가 π/2일 때 남극에 닿고, 그 다음 α가 π/2에서 π로 증가하면서 구의 반대편을 통해 북극으로 돌아와요.
이건 다 말이 되는데, 첫째로 이것들이 실수 벡터이기 때문에 허수 부분이 항상 0이고, 둘째로
각도 α가 Bloch 구에서 효과적으로 두 배가 되기 때문이에요. 이것도 배각 공식의 사용으로 설명할 수 있어요.
Bloch 구가 qubit의 순수 상태에 대한 아주 멋진 기하학적 표현을 제공한다는 걸 봤어요.
구 위의 각 점은 qubit의 고유한 순수 상태에 해당하고, 반대로도 마찬가지예요.
Bloch 공이라고 할 때는 Bloch 구 위의 모든 점과 그 안에 포함된 점들도 이야기하는 거예요.
Bloch 공 내부의 점들도 qubit 상태에 해당해요.
구체적으로는 순수 상태가 아닌 상태예요. 즉, 밀도 행렬로는 표현할 수 있지만 qubit 상태 벡터로는 표현할 수 없는 qubit 상태예요.
Bloch 공의 근본적인 측면과 내부 점이 비순수 상태를 나타내는 방식은,
Bloch 공 내부 점들의 볼록 조합이 밀도 행렬들의 볼록 조합에 해당한다는 거예요.
직관적으로 말하면, 기하학이 Bloch 공 내부에서도 완벽하게 작동한다는 의미예요.
몇 가지 예시를 살펴볼게요. 완전히 혼합된 상태를 나타내는 Bloch 공의 중심점부터 시작할게요.
완전히 혼합된 상태는 0과 1 상태를 평균해서 얻어요. 이건 구의 중심이 북극과 남극의 정확히 중간에 있다는 사실과 일치해요.
실제로 플러스와 마이너스 상태나 플러스 i와 마이너스 i 상태 같은 두 대척점의 정확히 중간이에요.
Bloch 구에서 대척점들은 항상 직교하는 순수 상태에 해당해요. 이게 드러내거나 반영하는 건,
완전히 혼합된 상태를 항상 임의의 두 직교하는 순수 qubit 상태의 평균으로 쓸 수 있다는 거예요.
이를 보는 또 다른 방법은 완전히 혼합된 상태의 Pauli 행렬 표현을 생각하는 거예요.
이걸 만족시키려면 항등이 아닌 세 Pauli 행렬의 계수를 모두 0으로 설정해야 해요.
따라서 Bloch 공 안의 해당 점은 원점 한가운데에 있어요. 그런데 밀도 행렬의 Pauli 행렬 표현을 이렇게 생각하면
Bloch 공 점들의 볼록 조합이 밀도 행렬들의 볼록 조합에 해당한다는 게 꽤 명확해져요.
밀도 행렬의 평균이나 가중 평균을 취하고 모든 것을 Pauli 행렬의 선형 결합으로 표현하면,
물론 해당하는 점들을 평균하는 것과 같아요. 세 계수에서 모든 게 선형이기 때문이에요.
마지막 예시로, 수업 초반에 본 0 상태와 플러스 상태의 평균을 고려해 볼게요.
밀도 행렬 표현을 계산했는데 화면에 나타나 있어요. 그리고 그 점은 0과 플러스 상태의 중간 위치인 Bloch 공 내부에 있어요.
또 이 밀도 행렬을 스펙트럼 분해에 기반한 다른 방식으로 표현할 수 있다는 것도 봤는데,
그것도 다이어그램과 이전 예시들과 일치해요. 그리고 이걸로 Bloch 구와 Bloch 공에 대한 이야기를 마무리할게요.
사람들은 종종 세 개 이상의 고전적 상태를 가진 시스템에 대한 Bloch 구나 Bloch 공이 있는지 물어봐요.
안타깝게도 답은 사실상 없어요. 시스템의 양자 상태를 기하학적 측면에서 항상 생각할 수 있고,
Bloch 공과 유사하게요. 실수 벡터 공간에서 볼록 물체를 얻기는 해요.
하지만 세 개 이상의 고전적 상태가 있으면 구형이 되지 않아요. 예를 들어, 정확히 세 개의 고전적 상태,
즉 큐트릿이 있다면 8차원 공간의 볼록 물체를 얻어요. 하지만 그 물체의 극점들, 즉 큐트릿의 순수 양자 상태에 해당하는 것들은
4차원 다양체를 이루어요. 8차원 공간에서 4차원 다양체를 가져다가
수축 포장해서 볼록 물체를 만드는 걸 시각화할 수 있고, 그게 큐트릿에 대해 생각하는 유용한 방법이라고 생각한다면, 자유예요.
생각해볼 만한 흥미로운 내용이지만, 공이 아니에요. 그보다 더 복잡해요. 수업의 마지막 부분에서는 밀도 행렬이
다중 시스템에서 어떻게 작동하는지 간단히 이야기할 거예요. 밀도 행렬은 다중 시스템의 상태를 나타낼 수 있고,
이건 양자 상태 벡터와 완전히 유사한 방식으로 작동해요. 특히 양자 정보의 단순화된 공식화에서와 마찬가지로,
다중 시스템을 마치 단일 복합 시스템인 것처럼 볼 수 있어요.
이번에는 다중 시스템의 상태를 나타내는 밀도 행렬의 행과 열 모두
개별 시스템들의 고전적 상태 집합의 데카르트 곱과 대응되어 있어요.
예를 들어, 네 가지 벨 상태의 밀도 행렬 표현을 고려할 수 있어요.
이건 수업 초반에 다른 양자 상태 벡터들에 대해 했던 것처럼, 상태 벡터를 켤레 전치와 곱해서 정확히 같은 방식으로 얻어요.
결과는 화면에 나타나 있어요. 본질적으로 개념적 수준에서는 정말 새로운 게 없어요. 하지만 곧 밀도 행렬로 다중 시스템에서
할 수 있는 새로운 것들이 있다는 걸 보게 될 거예요.
독립성과 상관관계의 개념은 양자 상태 벡터에서 밀도 행렬로 이어져요. 특히 밀도 행렬의 텐서 곱이 시스템 간의 독립성을 나타낸다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
양자 상태 벡터에서 사용했던 것과 같은 용어를 사용해요. 예를 들어, 상태 ρ에 준비된 시스템 X와
독립적으로 상태 σ에 준비된 시스템 Y가 있다면, 쌍 XY의 상태는 ρ와 σ의 텐서 곱으로 주어져요.
이걸 곱 상태라고 해요. 이건 두 개 이상의 시스템으로 자연스럽게 일반화돼요.
곱 상태로 표현할 수 없는 밀도 행렬은 시스템 간의 상관관계를 나타내요. 이 부분은 양자 상태 벡터와 비슷해요.
하지만 밀도 행렬을 사용할 때는 심지어 두 시스템만 있어도 다양한 유형의 상관관계가 나타날 수 있어요.
이와 대조적으로, 양자 상태 벡터에서는 실제로 한 가지 유형의 상관관계만 가질 수 있어요.
그게 바로 얽힘이에요. 달리 말하면, 양자 상태 벡터에서는 상관관계와 얽힘이 동의어지만,